Пекінська капуста гниє просто обабіч дороги.
Це стихійне сміттєзвалище з городини влаштували українські фермери.
Через закриття найбільшого оптового ринку на Херсонщині
вони не можуть продати сезонну городину.
Аби хоч щось реалізувати, з півдня України на ринок "Столичний" до Києва
приїхав фермер Олександр Снігур.
Люди у Вознесенську повикидали редиску отак мішками. Її ніхто не бере.
Ніхто не бере. Нікому нічого не треба, бо продати не можемо.
Ось уже два дні не можемо продати три тонни редиски.
Через заборону діяльності продовольчих ринків по всій Україні зник оптовий покупець.
Тож, торгівля стоїть, і Олександр у розпачі думає, куди ж збувати достиглі овочі.
До того ж, він зібрав лише десяту частину врожаю, решта, ймовірно, залишиться гнити в землі.
Каже, це доцільніше, ніж наймати людей на збір та сортування редиски, а потім її викидати.
Кому вона потрібна?
Її стільки, будь ласка, поїдьте і візьміть.
У кожному селі, де її вирощують, можна просто на дитбудинки набрати.
Просто набрати, не треба нічого. Люди повиставляли попереду двору, край городів.
Через коронавірус продовольчі ринки в Україні закрили вже понад місяць тому.
Згодом міністерство охорони здоров'я рекомендувало відкрити ринки,
але лише за умови дотримання суворих санітарних вимог.
Зокрема дозволити працювати лише зареєстрованим ринкам,
які б забезпечили персонал індивідуальними засобами захисту
і належно контролювали б відстань між покупцями в черзі - не менше ніж півтора метри.
Також відстань між торговими точками мала бути не менша, ніж 3 метри.
Втім, для влади більшості українських міст і містечок
легше було просто закрити ринки, аніж проконтролювати їхню діяльність.
Навіть у Києві працює лише один оптовий ринок - "Столичний".
Якщо запевнять і буде сприяти цьому епідеміологічна ситуація,
то, можливо, послаблення цього режиму і буде.
Тим більше, що забороняти одним і дозволяти іншим - це трохи дискредитація.
Але змушені це робити, у зв’язку з тим, що неможливо контролювати роботу ринків так,
у повній мірі, як би нам цього хотілося б.
Ярмарки - це окрема ситуація, там взагалі контролю немає з боку організаторів.
Вони ж в основному надавали тільки місця.
І наша служба теж не така чисельна, щоб ми могли все покинути і займатися тільки ринками.
У середині квітня МОЗ вирішило таки заборонити роботу продовольчих ринків -
після того, як від коронавірусу помер один з директорів ринку в Запоріжжі.
Таке рішення уряду може знищити українського фермера,
вважають експерти українського проекту бізнес-розвитку плодоовочівництва (UHBDP).
До проекту входять майже 40 тисяч малих та середніх виробників
сільськогосподарської продукції.
Тут кажуть, що більше половини фермерів мають дохід лише від сільського господарства.
Вони не переживуть кризу, пов'язану із закриттям продовольчих ринків.
Це підтверджує і фермер з Рівненщини Вадим.
Його обурює, що в супермаркетах теж на кожному кроці порушують умови карантину,
однак їхню роботу не припиняють.
Та й ціни там значно вищі.
Йому ж навпаки - через низький попит доводиться знижувати оптову ціну до мінімуму.
Люди в супермаркет ідуть, а ринки не працюють.
Виростили, а не можемо продати, навіть те, що вклали. Огірок віддаємо… працюємо в нуль.
Собівартість виростити кілограм огірка - до 20 гривень,
а продаємо по 28-30 гривень оптом.
Для чого таке робити?
У нас люди, які займаються теплицями в Рівненській області, взагалі кажуть:
або закривати, або що робити…
Державної підтримки, яка б компенсувала збитки фермерів, немає.
Але навіть, якби була, переважна більшість не змогла б її отримати,
адже, за різними оцінками, 80 відсотків плодоовочевого бізнесу працює в тіні.
Господарствам було легше реалізовувати продукцію на базарах,
аніж виходити на інші ринки збуту, приміром, на супермаркети.
У статистиці відображені як особисті сільські господарства,
а люди числяться в центрах зайнятості як безробітні.
Насправді вони вирощують свою городину чи ягоди.
Відповідно вони психологічно, ментально не готові легалізуватися, мають бути якісь стимули.
Але є й поодинокі приклади тих, хто навпаки виграв від карантину та закриття ринків,
як, приміром, фермерське господарство Антона Дундія з Київщини.
Ось капуста кейл: вона існує різних видів і, відповідно, зовсім різна на смак…
Фермер уже четвертий рік продає вирощені в своєму господарстві овочі та зелень
не на ринку, а напряму споживачам.
І нині попит зріс удвічі.
Спершу через соцмережі покупці можуть обрати різні кошики: великий 500 гривень і малий - 250.
Вміст кошиків залежить від сезону.
Після замовлення за день-два продукцію розвозять по Києву.
Правильна схема роботи: коли виробник якомога ближче до споживача,
тоді він може бачити, що він їсть і як воно вирощується.
І той, хто виробляє, отримує клієнта напряму.
І наскільки він гарно працює, настільки в нього багато клієнтів.
Якщо люди цього не бояться - фермери, я маю на увазі, то вони тільки виграють від цього.
Продавати через інтернет у часи карантину почали й інші господарства,
приміром, фермери із Запоріжжя доставляють листя салату,
щавель та іншу сезонну продукцію "Новою поштою".
А міністерство розвитку економіки, торгівлі і сільського господарства
тим часом готує перелік вимог, які регулюватимуть роботу продуктових ринків
в умовах карантину.
Тим не менше власники ринків не вірять, що їм дозволять спокійно працювати,
як, приміром, директор оптового ринку "Неждана" на Херсонщині.
Після перерви ринок знову почав працювати для гуртових покупців.
Кожен день ми робили санітарне прибирання і обро бку дезінфікуючими засобами.
У нас є все: термометри є, пов'язки є, рукавички є,
в кого немає - даємо, за гроші, без націнки.
Вимагаємо від людей, щоб дотримувалися дистанції. Кожен день комісія.
Все шукають причину, щоб закрити ринок. Бо ринок закритий - значить, немає проблеми.
Чиновники пишуть інструкції такі, щоб їх неможливо було виконати.
Щоб прийти, перевірити, виписати штраф і взяти хабар, я не побоюсь цього слова.
Вони хабарники всі.
Карантин в Україні продовжили поки до 11 травня.
В останньому рішенні Кабміну про послаблення протиепідеміологічних заходів
для міських ринків не йшлося.
Фермери занепокоєні, бо окрім овочів вже достигли полуниця та інші ягоди.
А через відсутність попиту ціна на на першу ягоду вже й так рекордно низька.